on est très agitée aujourd'hui c'est la
dernière semaine les cherry et ce soir
dans le public j'avais très envie
d'avoir mes jumeaux mes jumeaux d'amour
de à prendre ou à laisser
qui ont vécu une aventure incroyable
jeudi soir un record d'audience
on a vu ça pourra prendre ou à laisser
et avec un pic à près de 1 million 700
mille téléspectateurs tu es mon fils ce
week-end qui m'a donné l'idée de vous
inviter qui croient faire un toc toc toc
spécial sport toc toc toc qui est là
judo judo qui ôte judo czaja bien sûr
attaque atteint dja dja djedje odiah
cébazat weppes a piqué pas ça tu veux me
pécho basket causses je suis très énervé
pourquoi pas il ya un chroniqueur ou une
chroniqueuse ici qui nous a caché une
activité meddahi mme
je vous ai trouvé vous êtes sur un site
mais non non non tender c'est pire que
ça un mature dating pacte c'est pas du
tout prévu en fait c'est que y'a juste
olic mais non ils étaient juste un mois
là cet après-midi parce qu'on organisait
les vacances on va dire la vérité aux
gens voilà on organisait des vacances de
cet été en somme parce qu'on va déjà
faire partir quelques jours ensemble et
on fait et la voile et m'a dit voitures
de seconde je me mets sur le canapé et
si tu sais moi je suis fan donc à chaque
fois je kiffe et je voyage dans les
réunions je te vois travailler tout
c'est comme si je vais voir un pote dans
son lieu de travail donc ça me fait mal
c'était pas plus tard qu'il ya quelques
minutes voilà on a volé quelque chose
dans ma loge tu auras besoin de
quelqu'un qui sont les choses un
enquêteur hors pair
quelqu'un qui a envie de faire partie de
la police matthieu delormeau
enfin ce que tu veux dire j'aurai besoin
de vous avez besoin de l'inspecteur ou
de londres quelqu'un volet instruit
normal âge as-tu volée laurange
d'hanouna non as-tu voler leur ange de
non non répond sophie avoue tout de
suite ce sera plus simple
je n'ai pas volé le range d'alona si tu
dis la vérité maintenant tu pourra
encore être pardonné dans quelques
minutes ce sera trop tard la sanction
tombera regardez mathieu ont regardé et
qui haïssent a volé lors aux chaudes
hanouna y voler le orange je vous jure
c'est bien moi qui ai volé long range
le carton type de temps après que jean
bracq et sac à dos il peut faire une
stratégie d'air ça me suis gouré a pas
mal souffert et je fais ring et la wii
dont celle là c'est quoi ton est juste
un voile assez corsé tu disais non mais
là c'est là c'est du lourd et s'est
évanoui
c'est un gars et fongiques c'est du haut
niveau là sûr que non là c'est
clairement c'est pas c'est pas possible
quoi on va marquer la personne mais
c'est normal je connais
avant toi à votre leur match mc radieux
on va pas aller loin de coluche et le
luron et c'est vrai qu'elle sur l'accord
unedic absolument pas dans la merde
famille catastrophe
il faut absolument que le clubbing gros
ils voient je suis discothèque
vous devez soutenir les discothèques je
vous demande de soutenir tous les
discothèques
il faut que nous rouvrirons merci mon
jeu rock d'être un nouveau thème fort et
agent et c'est vrai parce que on pense à
tous les restaurateurs qui ont ouvert il
faut faire travailler la france cet été
un mine de rien faut faire travailler
nos amis voilà et nos amis des
restaurateurs dans toute la france les
bars les restaurants voilà tout ça parce
que je pense franchement on a besoin
d'eux et les mecs y à quoi et à qui à
quoi comme plus grand kiff que d'aller
boire un verre en terrasse comme ici
avec des potes
allez on y va c'est parti radi a amené
moi quelqu'un à témoin darmon sur elana
guardian a renchéri bon jour pour jour
pourquoi la motion et vadim étoiles à
aller c'est quand il a quoi gâter il a
quoi gagner la télé alerte elle était
prêt alors je me souviens de ce rendez
vous avec toi pour faire de la radio
j'étais tellement flipper que j'ai été
faire pipi trois fois fit est arrivé et
tu m'as dit t'inquiète pas j'adore tes
cheveux c'est bon c'est signé j'ai pas
pu aller jusqu'au bout de la saison j'ai
arrêté avant la fin à cause des
livraisons tu m'a regardé dans les yeux
et tu m'as dit raymond si tu t'amuses
plus faut partir est athée livraison va
faire tes livraison mais regarde moi
bien sûr la tête de ma mère que je ne
lâche pas je me suis dit bon c'est des
phrases qu'on dit comme ça dans ce
métier là à mon avis la suite tu la
connais je la connais l'amitié
s'installe nos texto on échange ton
envie de me remettre à chaque fois à
l'antenne de pas me lâcher
touche pas à mon sport l'an penses quoi
tp mp3 fois trois échecs tu viens me
voir et tu me dis ça ne marchera jamais
citer pas toi-même les conseils toujours
les conseils la bienveillance malgré nos
désaccords tu cherche toujours à me
protéger tel un grand frère boulot les
gens me disaient bravo raymond continue
comme ça à la télé ça motive et ça
motivait pour toutes ces raisons je suis
contente que la vie mais fait croiser
ton chemin je suis fier d'être près de
toi je suis fier d'être ton pote mon
cyril hanouna cela distrait ma vie je
t'aime série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai la saison a été longue
je me suis parfois énervé plusieurs fois
j'ai eu des accrochages avec mathieu
mais faut que les gens sachent que c'est
des gens qu'on va pu me tirer dans les
pattes c'est des gens qu'on a pu me
mettre de côté quand vas tu ne peut pas
m'aider à chaque fin d'émission
et quand tu ne sais combien de fois j'ai
voulu me barrer s'est dit demain je vais
donc me barre tous les textos que j'ai
reçu de chacun t'inquiète pas ça va
aller c'est comme ça à la télé voilà je
voudrais dire aux gens quand on parle de
famille il ya ceux qui nous aiment pas
et c'est pas grave continue et pas nous
aimer c'est votre choix et ceux qui nous
aiment
mais quand on parle de famille allait
elle est là quoi que vous pensiez elle
est quand même là la famille merci moi
et moi je voudrais dire
l'année dernière j'avais dit que c'est
trop chaud à kelly était la révélation
de l'année pour moi cette année je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord avec franchement
raymond direct qui a explosé cette année
on va pas se mentir les tout cas je vous
ramassez c'est surtout les
téléspectateurs aussi qui nous
soutiennent à fond et qui sont là dans
tous nos projets de merci mais ça paraît
bien voilà merci que tu apprends rapport
doit laisser très spécial et séries
toutes les sommes sont doublés black
angie avec moi vous pouvez passer si
vous voulez voir y'a pas de problème les
chérissait la dernière ce soir c'est
parti on est en direct a tout de suite
sur l'autre place